[Music]
is it lame to change your name just to
avoid blame
facebook ceo mark zuckerberg aka shaved
gerbil head
has announced that's his name has
announced his company will be rebranding
itself meta
he says it's all about aligning with his
virtual reality vision for the future
which he detailed in a 90-minute video
this week we now pause to watch all 90
minutes
with no interruptions
it is time for us to adopt a new company
brand to encompass everything that we do
to reflect who we are and what we hope
to build
i am proud to announce that starting
today our company is now
meta
oh yes
he's so completely relatable
yeah that's meta like he's never met a
fellow human being before
he's as relatable
it's true he's as relatable as bringing
silly string to a funeral i don't know
what he is
he says the new meta name will better
encompass what they do which is reaching
beyond social media
meta comes from the greek word meaning
beyond
yes ladies i am bilingual
plus i speak two languages
you can't help
but wonder if it's a response to all the
bad press facebook has been getting
lately
alec baldwin's had a better week
but you know what
we need more of zuckerberg picking out
an outfit
and it has an incredibly inspiring view
of whatever you find most beautiful
hey are you coming yeah just gotta find
something to wear
all right
perfect yeah
perfect
let's have some more of this crap
one example that we're seeing take off
is fitness and speaking of that i think
it's time for my workout
a lot of you are already using quest to
stay fit it lets you work out in some
completely new ways it's kind of like a
peloton but instead of a bike you just
have your vr headset and with it you can
do anything from boxing lessons to sword
fighting to even dancing even dancing
he reminds me of a sex robot but without
the sex
[Laughter]
cat is this just proof that he doesn't
have any friends yes yes thank you
that's exactly what it's proof of
because you know he's very very rich
which you think you know you could do
something about being like that
like i always thought that money could
buy more than it really can right yeah
like you could get a coach she'd be like
humans don't do that but
you can't i just don't understand like
he all the money in the world and you
come up with meta yes that's what
everybody's come up with after like a
couple whippets
[Laughter]
whatever those are why were metamucil
that's funny if i ever met a mucil i
would sue him
you know uh amanda um you are a
filmmaker so let's say doesn't this
remind you of the michael crichton movie
disclosure
do you remember that movie
yes but it's crazy it's so much creepier
than like anything people have so far
actually created in order to be creepy
like the dystopian future of just
watching that i already i just want out
like i'm done i'm out but the thing
that's really weird about it is like
these social media companies think that
they're going to be moving towards this
like meta uh you know vr world they
might want to stop like just banning
people all the time and like censoring
them because basically what's going to
entice anyone to get into this weird vr
world where they're just going to be
like you can come into the vr world and
sit here and be quiet yeah and you're
like yeah i'm good i don't i don't need
like i can't connect with anybody anyway
so like why would i do this so i mean
it's yeah it's a little crazy it's
interesting but if you get canceled in
this world you get cancelled into next
right yeah do you yeah nice i see that
excellent well done yeah speaking of
filmmakers yeah huh
it's all in here
jimmy zuckerberg uh is what would happen
if the robot from small wonder
transitioned oh
that's good that's very good
i agree remember vicky yeah vicky
doesn't who doesn't remember vicky it's
a deep cop maybe vicky
it's a deep cut uh what i find so
fascinating about this is how with a
straight face they're not acknowledging
why the rebrand is happening it's
happening why because the branding is
toxic there's two types of couples that
renew their wedding vows one is they're
married 25 or 50 years they're adorable
their grandkids are there they want a
bunch of pictures the other is they're
married seven he knocked up a stewardess
and they just want to rebrand and start
from scratch which by the way
if no one's doing anything on sunday my
wife and i are getting married
but
but that's all this is as a reset and
what's funny is that they're not
acknowledging why the reset is is
because everyone on the left is mad at
them because they didn't you know censor
conservatives enough right so this is
the declaration that there's more coming
i i hate him i'm sorry yeah you know all
right so robbie you're going to be the
benefactor of my theory which is that
this is if if
zucker is creating a simulation there's
going to be a moment in time where in
that simulation you'll be able to create
another simulation and if you can
simulate in the forward direction what
does that tell us about the backward
that we right now we're in simulation
yeah because he's creating a simulation
inside that's a simulation simulation's
all the way down i am not high i think
i do believe i have a stomach flu which
could be making me crazy but maybe it's
a glitch in the matrix yes you're
experiencing some kind of uh bad or
diarrhea
no it's almost like he's inventing it
i'm listening to him describe here's how
you'll do fitness and change clothes are
you pivoting to real life yeah are you
just like inventing the opposite of
social media just like going about your
day that suit he's coming around to go
outside
but it is i know how to do that already
but it is funny that just like jimmy
said republicans democrats everyone
biden trump everyone every political
figure mad at this company wants to
regulate it out of existence and i'm
just thinking why it's done it is over
it will it's a dying star it will never
command you think it's done it will
never command the political social and
cultural relevance that it commanded
three years ago this is there's and vr
might be the future this guy's not going
to invent it it's going to be some other
company his company's done interesting
all right all right hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else